Yeah,
18.
If you haven't, uh, picked up notes
or whatever you'd like to do, go ahead and do that.
We have them sessions, the
verses and things like that.
We'll get started. David tells me it's time to start.
I do what tells you to do often,
not all the time, but often.
Well, welcome. Uh, my name's Steve Murdoch,
and, uh, Maybe I need this,
but, uh, I had the privilege of serving as one
of your elders and, uh,
and been serving in that role
for a little over five, no four years.
And, uh, Lewis and Ryan Whitaker
and I came on at the same time.
And there were a total of, uh, nine of us, Alan,
and that's there in the back, and John
and Aaron back in the back.
And, uh, and then our newest elders, uh, Trevor, uh,
Chris and Dan.
I think Trevor will be teaching next week,
and then Chris will be following the
next 12 weeks after that.
And, uh, and then Dan has previously
taught us a couple sessions.
So, um, Joe Williams is currently on sabbatical.
And, uh, prior to serving as an elder, I was a deacon
and my wife Denise, and I lead a community group.
And we've been at Henderson for nearly 19 years.
Uh, I've also had the great joy
of working in the cafe twice a month as, uh, a baker.
Um, you know,
everything we've made in new cafe is from scratch
and, uh, not really.
And I have a, so, uh, people will come in
and say, they'll do the line
and say, you know, I'm really kind of watching what I eat,
so I think I'll have a scone instead of a donut.
Lemme just give you the, there's really no,
there's not better for you,
but if it makes you feel good, that's okay.
Uh, you know, I, uh, at least I've been married
for 42 years, and, uh, we have two daughters,
Mallory Stoltz, uh, who serves
as a women's ministry director here, our church,
her husband is Jason, who's part of the worship band,
and they lead a community group.
And they have our two oldest grandchildren, deacon,
who will turn 12 on December 7th,
and Salem, who turns 11 tomorrow.
Our other daughter, Maggie Nichols,
and her husband David, are part
of the group from Henderson Hills that, uh,
planted Providence Baptist and are serving there with Brett
and a lot of other folks.
Maggie has her own communications
and fundraising consulting business
and serves on the Edmond City Council for some crazy reason.
Uh, David serves an assistant United States attorney
for the Western District of Oklahoma,
and we have our two youngest grandchildren, uh, Corey,
who turns eight on November 3rd,
and married, who turned five on October 21st.
Mallory's Mallory's birthday is on November 13th.
Denise's birthday is on December 9th,
and Maggie's birthday is on December 28th.
So these are busy birthday times for us.
I just mentioned that because it seems to be the focus
of our family right now.
Uh, I retired almost two years ago
after serving here, 36 years as a city attorney lived Mond.
And tonight, uh, I'll spend most of my time talking
and sharing about prayer.
A little bit of brief time on angels and Satan and demons.
And I'll turn it over to Jacob, uh, who will, uh,
he will close with, uh, uh, more information about that,
and we'll close with him
and prayer like we normally do, as I'm sure many of you do.
Uh, I read several devotionals every day, usually
between five 30 and six o'clock in the morning.
And, uh, several couple of 'em I've been,
i I use right now is, uh, it's, uh, called Truth
for Life, Alistair Bay.
And then, you know, it's purely a coincidence that, uh,
is the topic for his little devotional today, was
that the Devil Defanged
and, uh, talked about demons
and domain of darkness, truly coincidence.
And then the other, uh, devotional that I read,
read this Morning with Truth for Life, uh, C Per,
and the title was How Do We Pray The, so
they weren't, I didn't talk to those guys about
what we were gonna talk about tonight,
but, uh, I think that's, uh, pretty amazing to me.
I sat there this morning and looked at those, I said, well,
Lord, is servingly our time.
So one other thing I just want to mention, uh,
really in conjunction with prayer,
the Elder Council meets the first
and third Tuesday of each month in the church office,
and we always start our meeting in prayer,
and we consider it a privilege
and a blessing to have the opportunity to pray with members.
And each of you're welcome to meet with the elders
for prayer and for other issues.
Uh, we card at six o'clock
and, uh, I think I can speak for all my brothers that, uh,
one of the greatest poses we have is to pray, um,
and pray for each one of you.
And, uh, so, uh, I think my paper was out.
I have my email address as well
as the elder's Counsel email, email address.
So please feel free to contact us at any time
to schedule a time to meet with us.
We, um, a lot of times the prayers relate to health issues
and things like that, but they also relate
to just things going on in people's lives. And,
Uh, It's a privilege for us to pray.
So why don't we begin our time in prayer
and, uh, let's do that.
So, heaven, me, father, I, I thank, uh, you
for the opportunity to be together with these folks.
And, uh, I pray that you'll bless our time together.
We praise you, we praise your name.
We're thankful for the things that you do for us.
We thank you for the privilege of prayer,
for the opportunity to confess our sins
before you, for the opportunity to present requests to you,
for the opportunity to listen to you
as we communicate with you.
Lord, I just thank you for our time together tonight.
I pray your blessings upon each one of us.
Pray for good health. Pray for those
that are struggling in various areas of their life.
Pray for encouragement. So, Lord, bless our time, me pray.
Thank
So prayer defined
a lot of different definitions
or thoughts about what prayer is.
Um, short answer might be personal communication with God.
Hebrews four 16 says, let us then with confidence, draw near
to the throne of grace, that we may receive mercy
and find grace to help in time of need,
The confidence that we have to draw near to the throne
of grace that
should provide comfort.
John Newton put the opportunity of prayer wonderfully well.
He said, approach my soul, the mercy seat
where Jesus answered prayer.
They're humbled before his feet for none.
Parish there by promises, by only plea with this venture,
I, I thou call us burden souls to be
and such, oh Lord, am I
Written In 1779, the opportunity to be at the foot
in mercy seat to be near man's chief end is
to glorify God and to enjoy him forever.
So how better to glorify God
and to enjoy him through prayer.
I think about that prayer is an offering up
of our desires unto God.
The things agreeable to his will in the name of Christ
with confession of our sins
and thankful acknowledgement Of his mercies.
The Westminster shorter categories.
Well, during my training to be an elder,
I was given a book and paddled prayer.
And how praying together shapes the church by John with uk
and he suggests several di several definitions for prayer.
And he quotes several other offers.
He says, prayer is talking to God.
Well, we kind of covered that. Communicate with God.
He says, prayer is demanding something from God.
Well, demanding is kind of a hard word for me,
but I guess when we request things, when we're asking
for something, uh, prayer is aligning our will
with God's.
He said, prayer is more for you than it is for God.
Prayer is more for you than it's for God.
Prayer is wishful thinking aimed in God's direction.
Prayer is some combination of all these things.
Gary Villard has written a book on prayer entitled,
calling on the name of the Lord,
a Biblical Theology of Prayer.
His conclusion, prayer is calling on God
to come through on his promise.
The first in instance of recorded prayer in the Bible,
the courages in Genesis chapter four, outside
of the Garden of Eden.
In Genesis four verses 25 to 26, it says,
and Adam knew his wife again and she bore his son
and called his name Seth Verse.
He said, God has appointed from me another offspring instead
of Abel, for Cain killed him.
'cause Seth also a son was born
and he called his name Enoch.
At that time, people began
to call upon the name of the Lord.
The commentary on these verses states
that Adam Eve have another son, Seth.
These people want God to fulfill his promise, even if
that day isn't today, when people begin
to call on his promise of his son,
who will reverse the curse
and defeat of the circuit,
John Calvin has asserts prayer in the Bible's intimately
linked to the gospel, God's promise and
provided solution to the problem of you
and against him and its consequences.
The gospel shape of prayer is evident
for the opening pages of the Bible.
And in particular, Genesis 4 26, when people first begin
to call him the name of Yahweh, right through the end,
when the church pray, come Lord Jesus in Revelation 2020.
Throughout, throughout the entire Bible, in a sense
the prayer is saying, are we there yet?
God? Prayer brings about the things
that you promised you would, prayer in the Bible is linked
to the hope of redemption and thus the gospel.
Finally, you might think a prayer is God's prescription
for life in the fall in the world.
I, a couple
different types of prayer.
Well, there's the prayer for poten, petition
or intervention, prayers of confession of sin,
prayers of adoration, praises
and thanksgiving.
God's communicating to us as his response.
So why do we pray?
Any thoughts about why we pray
The Bible tell you.
I was gonna say obedience is Obed one of them?
Does it express our trust in God?
Absolutely Dependence. We love him.
We want to have fellowship with him.
One of the best ways to do that,
I think our example is Jesus, right?
He pray a lot, A lot.
God allows us as creatures to be involved in,
in activities that are eternally important.
Praying for others, praying for the salvation
of other people, praying for wisdom, praying for the wisdom
decision to make our wi better.
Those of us who have had children praying for the salvation
of our children, family members,
difficult, difficult circumstances, healing.
So pray for our leaders. Pray for our leaders, pray
for one another, pray for boldness.
Boldness in our, in our
testimony, forgiveness.
We give glory to God in our prayers. Mm-hmm.
So how does prayer work?
James? Four, two says, you do not have,
because you do not ask.
Luke 11, nine through 10 says, and I tell you, ask
and it'll be given to you.
Seek and you will find knock. And it'll be open to you.
For everyone who asks, receives, and the one who seeks fines
and to the one who knocks, it will be open.
Question, How
much do we actually pray
For? What,
How often should we pray?
Without season, without
Season?
So what is the minimum amount
of time should we be spending in prayer?
And so
what about prayer without cing verse Thessalonians five 17.
How do we, how do we evaluate ourselves?
And how much time we pray, is that a tough question to ask?
Sometimes we hear a catch ourselves
wondering, I should have prayed about that,
or I prayed about that
and I'm not sure got my response.
So do I need to pray again?
Your Relationship, how
Was it?
Mm-hmm.
Is it more than just a blessing of a meal? Is it,
it's a tough one for often, um, husbands and wives
and been something that Denise
and I have not done as well as we should, is pray
with our wives and our spouses.
Uh, Our family members.
Luke 18, one it says,
and he told 'em a parable to the effect
that they ought always to pray and not lose heart.
Then there is second Chronicle, seven 14.
If my people who are called by my name humble themselves
and pray and seek my face
and turn from their wicked ways,
then I will hear from heaven and their sin
and heal their land.
So it sounds like current,
I have an element of humility there. Um,
Because We often think about,
or I often think about, I can kind of do this on my own,
and then when the times get a little
difficult, maybe it's the time.
That's a confession. I have,
I remember in the years past when, uh, I was working
for a living and, uh,
I'd be down at the Oklahoma County Courthouse and,
and I'd be involved in something
that I thought was pretty important at the time,
and I might have some anxiety on my way there, thinking,
well, how's this gonna turn out?
Maybe after being down there for a couple days,
trying a lawsuit or something
and going back to the parking garage
and coming out on maybe the, a good end of a decision
making, the Lord thank you.
I really appreciate that.
Thank you for being with me
during this difficult circumstance, during something that
I thought was important at the time.
Um, And then I think, whoa, was it okay
to pray for a good decision?
What I was doing? Um, thought it was, uh,
that I remember to be grateful, uh, that I remember
to be thankful, that I remember to be humble and, and,
and how it turned out that I remember to pray.
What? It didn't turn out as good as it, I hope
because there was a judge
who felt like something different should happen.
But still be thankful that,
so I, I go back to how often should we prayer?
How much do we ask for pray?
And I think that's something we should always
constantly be thinking
About.
I dunno if we can over pray.
That's that be my experience.
Next topic, I think I had on the outline of
Jesus Christ, our mediator.
And the question that I wrote here, um, I think I said,
does God hear the prayer of unbeliev?
Let's say we about the prayer, hear God hear the answer,
hearing prayer, thoughts?
Is that a question we talk about? Yes.
Variable image
reflect His who He's in our life.
So you gotta start somewhere, right?
Anybody else? No.
Steve, do you, do you mean hear the prayer
or do you mean like, honor
and listen with an intent
to answer the prayer?
There is a distinction. This could be two different things.
Those are two different things God
always hears in the sense he is aware
of the prayers made by him believers.
And he may from time to time answer their prayers out
of his mercy and in his,
and in a desire to bring him in to salvation through Christ.
However, God has nowhere promised to respond
to the prayers of unbelievers.
The only prayers that he has promised to hear in the sense
of listening with his, Dan says, a sympathetic here
and an undertaking to answer when they're made, according
to his book, are the prayers of Christians offered
through the one mediator of Jesus Christ.
Compare this statement that was made by Rudo
to John 14, six.
Jesus said to him, I'm the way, the truth and alive.
No one comes to the Father except for me.
So this idea of coming through Jesus
according to is
Will I?
That that was the question about God is omni, Omni,
I know I may not even pronounce that word,
but all rolling.
All hearing. But the fact that he would've,
the sympathetic ear
Would Be a distinction. Yes.
He listened to Cornelius mm-hmm. Um,
So much that he sent Peter over.
Go, go talk to him.
So Cornelius didn't know Jesus yet, but he was seeking God
and God heard that. Yeah.
Which we believe what led to the salvation. Yeah.
Letter I had written down. In whose name do we pray?
John 14, 13 through 14 says, whatever you ask in my name,
this I will do that.
The Father may be glorified in the Son.
If you ask me anything in my name, I will do it.
The question, should we pray to Jesus
and or to the Holy Spirit?
I think Gdo says it, it doesn't hurt. Yeah.
It's not going to hurt anything. They are one Yeah,
God the Father, God the Son, the Holy Spirit
don't remember thinking a lot about
praying to the Holy Spirit.
Um, but David gives a good answer. It doesn't hurt.
Uh, There's no prayers directly addressed
to the Holy Spirit or reported in the New Testament.
There's nothing that would forbid such
prayer for the Holy Spirit.
Like the Father of the Son is fully, God is worthy
of prayer and is powerful.
To answer our prayer, he is our helper,
our advocate, or our counselor.
The Court agreement does not seem wrong
to pray directly to the Holy Spirit when you were asking him
to do something, relates directly to his special areas
of ministry or responsibility,
or agreed in further state,
that since this is not due testament pattern,
it should not become the dominant
emphasis in our prayer life.
Something think about. So think
About, um,
So how can I be sure that my prayers will be affected?
Make sure it's within his will.
Okay. Know God wo
About Who He's, what's his character?
What does he want for us?
Humble.
His chest. Right.
Well, you know, I, Matthew six,
I wrote the King James version, I think in my notes.
But
ES these says, pray then like this.
Our father and heaven hall be your name.
Your kingdom come,
your will be done on earth as it is in heaven.
Give us a stay our daily bread
and forgive our debts as we also have given our headers.
Us not implementation, but deliverance from evil.
Provide as the kingdom and the power and the glory forever.
Amen. King James burden. Yeah.
So pray according to God's will, praying with faith,
praying to be obedient.
Be something to pray for, something
that you really weren't willing to be obedient to
what God wants you to do.
Um, Confession of sins. We've mentioned that.
Praying for forgiving others. Humility.
Um, Good pattern there.
Um,
think back, many of you, I believe I've heard a lot
of prayers, worship services
And Bible studies
and things like that
kind of prayers have been from your memory
that have encouraged you think of any of those.
Say that again. Prayer in your memory
and your life experiences.
You've heard many prayers, perhaps you said some,
many prayers, but have there been any particular prayers
that stand out in your memory, um, that have been
of influenced to you or maybe a, a person
who you've heard many prayers
that have been an influence in your life?
I think real here, here recently was just learning how
to pray the Bible and, and giving adoration to God
and recognize who he's and what he's done with him.
Reading, praying through the Psalms. Right.
And that's really a whole for me.
Other thought. My mother every night at bedtime would pray
and Lord bless you and keep you and make us patient.
And I prayer for us as children for years and years, right.
That stands out.
My son said, thank you, God for the pizza
Mm-hmm.
Really resonated. Just simple.
Right? It's
Profound.
Wonderful.
I love when the, uh, there's occasion to pray
for maybe some missionaries that are being sent out mm-hmm.
For some occasion where we corporately pray
and send those stand out
Prayers when we stand around
a deacon, stand around an elder
or probation prayers, things like that.
I, uh, my personal experience was I didn't grow up
really going to church much at all.
And, um, got into junior high
and, uh, started going
to church in Oklahoma City called the Baptist Temple.
And, uh, It's Southern Baptist,
very strongly Southern Baptist.
And, uh, We would, uh,
there was one gentleman that was called upon often
by our pastor, uh, pray at the end
of the Sunday Rather Divine.
And, uh, brother had of divine was up to retired.
Pastor had a voice, probably a church,
about two or 300 maybe.
And the thing that we would think about when
our pastor would call on Brother Divine
and pray as a seventh grader, how long is this prayer going
to last Divine could
pray some law for?
And they were good prayers. That's a word.
Uh, but I guess it, it took me a while to realize,
Um, The importance of listening
to brother prayers and how the Lord had gifted him.
And so there are folks who are very gifted in
how they pray, uh, aloud.
Um, and so, um, that's a memory that I have to think about.
Um, How about unanswered prayers?
Um, there will always be unanswered prayers.
Why? Because we do not know God's wise timing.
We do not know, always know how to pray as we ought to.
We do not always pray according to God's will.
James four, three, you ask and do not receive
because you have asked wrongly to spend it on your passions.
And when you not always ask in faith, James one
and six through eight says, but let him ask in faith
with no doubting for the one who doubts is like a wave
of the sea is driven and tossed by the wind.
So that person must not suppose
that he will receive anything from the Lord.
He is a double-minded man, a stable normal players.
So we sometimes jump ahead,
Uh, Maybe sometimes think that we should,
uh, our prayer should be answered more quickly than they
are, or we not asking you the will.
All things to think about.
Sometimes it occurs that not the answer
the way in which we expect.
And that could be very, very difficult.
Praying for the healing of Russell, praying for comfort,
praying to sustain us in times of grief.
I contend prayers serious. It's serious business.
It's not to be avoid.
One of the essential elements of prayer is
praise and thanksgiving.
Matthew six, nine.
We've already shared this verse,
but we want to emphasize our Father in heaven.
How would be your name? So what does Hollywood mean?
A good friend Aaron Ferguson has taught me
to look in Noah Webster's 1828 dictionary
because Haitz says, consecrated to a sacred use
or to a religious exercise is to be reverenced.
I looked up reverenced to be regarded with fear, mingled
with respect and affection.
We go approaching God, uh, with this feeling
of it's a sacred exercise, a sacred opportunity
to communicate with God
and to do it in such a way that I, I'm somewhat fearful,
but I I I'm, I'm saying it with respect,
I'm saying it with affection.
What a way to start our prayer.
One of the first verses I memorized
after being saved
as a seventh grader at Falls Creek Baptist Assembly
in Davis, Oklahoma,
among about 5,000 other people, was Philippians four, six.
It says, do not be anxious about anything,
but in everything by prayer
and supplication with thanksgiving.
Let your request be made on the God
by each director suggested it tonight.
You memorized that first, Steve.
It's been helpful. Colossians four, two,
continue steadfastly in prayer, being watchful in it
with Thanksgiving, one
of my top favorite words in the Bible, steadfast, along
with ponder verse Thessalonians five 18.
I meant to reference verses 16 through 18.
But rejoice, always pray without ceasing.
Give thanks in all circumstances.
But this is the will of God in Christ Jesus for you.
So do you have a regular time each day
for private Bible reading and prayer?
I want ask for a show of hands,
but I'm guessing is this group of people
that I'm looking at that you do.
So I want to ask a question.
How do you overcome distractions while you're playing?
I'm looking for the answer. 'cause a
wise group of folks here.
So how do you overcome distractions? Late, late at night?
Late late at night? Can you say that again?
How do you overcome distractions?
He said late, late at night. Other thoughts? Mine's early.
Early in the morning. Early in the morning.
I get up there, work two
to four is late, late at night.
So one person's late,
late at night person.
Earlier, early, early. Yeah.
Do you find yourself sometimes being distracted?
Our minds are racing a lot.
Other things are going on in our lives. We think about,
Um, One
of our greatest distractions is this.
Um, That's also one of our greatest, who
Sometimes I use worshiping To pray worshiping. Okay.
I use that as a Prayer. Right. Alright.
You pray with others? Is
that helpful? Yeah.
We have a weekly group that meets on Mondays
and, um, when we share, we're write it down
and then when we pray for each other, it's written down.
That helps me to focus. Mm-hmm. Because we
Sitting On page. Right.
Right. Yeah. I have to write things down.
Um, Two or three different places perhaps.
I remembered to pray for, uh, about Danny Lane, friend
of mine lives morning Bible study this morning
talking about, uh,
he can had some eye surgery on, on Friday.
So I wrote that down in my book
and I put it in my calendar to remind me to pray for Danny
and to check on him and see, uh,
how he's doing about in the afternoon.
Just, that's fairly simple,
but if you don't write it down for me,
if I don't write it down, I'll, I'll probably forget
to forget it or have an opportunity to,
I also find it helpful to write down distractions like
that's to dos, come to mind, things that are important.
Like, you know, that's sometimes distraction,
but it helps me get it outta my head if I write it down.
Okay. Stop.
Flat it down and then we get back to,
because it's, it's there whether I like it or not.
Yeah. Get rid of it. Yeah. That's a good word.
Do you ever have trouble wondering what to correct?
I think that's where, what David was talking
back scripture mm-hmm.
And verse.
Mm-hmm. Yeah.
I, I wrote down the next thing I wrote down.
I have the commend praying scripture.
Um, You know, I've had the
opportunity, um, privilege, responsibility, whatever,
um, to pray, um,
in the worship service. And,
Um, The way that kind of works,
the worship team will contact one of us
and say, okay, this is your particular Sunday.
And, um, so
when I try to prepare for that, I always try
to make sure I'm praying things I praying for,
whether it's mission trips
or whether it's praying for coordination of deacons
or whatever it might be to pray a passage of scripture.
Very, very helpful, uh, for me and important for me.
And that's, that's listen to worship music,
praying scripture, um,
because that will cause so often will cause other things
that come to mind that you need remember to pray.
And, uh, and the
thoughts about things that I haven't covered,
but maybe come to mind.
I, you know, yeah. Steve,
I'm curious your thoughts, maybe other thoughts, like
what does it actually look like to pray without ccc?
Because we often, we often have a, a posture,
but we can't maintain that posture 24 7.
What, what, what does that look like?
Well, I have a friend
who I meet once a week named Kim Sw.
He is awesome in prayer,
and I am really bad at prayer, uh, really
like a first prayer when comes to prayer.
But he says, I'm not as bad as I think, I think he's lying
About That, just trying to comfort his friend.
Because when, when I do pray, it's kind
of whispered conversational prayers all day.
So I'll drive along and say, Lord, um,
you this sound is beautiful.
Oh, look out for that car. You know?
And so much so that when I was at university
that people see my lips move.
I robbed a professor, I'm an idiot.
Um, but maybe just conversational careers. Mm-hmm.
It's my only hope right here.
I always think of it too, is that we know
that God is ever present.
And so as I'm acknowledging and learning
and like seeing him
and recognizing him in every single thing,
like every distraction, everything that I'm doing,
everything that's going on, it's just an ongoing,
because he's ever present with me.
I can pray without Cece. Mm-hmm.
Go back to what Dan said, it's a posture
for sure of your heart.
And I have this posture in my heart all day that is just
really wanting to commune with him.
And if I have things to do
or everybody has things to do, that's okay.
You still, you lose that posture.
You just say, oh, I checked the box, I'm done.
I'll see you tomorrow. Mm-hmm.
Or do you just keep, you know, like Alan was saying,
I just keep commuting with him all day long
and Brenda all into the night until I'll just say,
you know, when you go to bed now down to sleep, I, my
probably awake.
I think it's like just acknowledging his presence
with us all the time.
Mm-hmm. So it's like if I'm with Brad, if I'm with Brad,
I can be in the car with him.
We're not having a conversation,
but I'm still, I mean, there's still a communication
that's going on mm-hmm.
Because I recognize that he's there with me.
Sometimes it's a conversation,
sometimes it's a deeper conversation.
Just if the acknowledgement ever present
Our relationship with, I want to
continue the, the fellowship with God.
Communication. Yeah.
Well, one tactical thing that is not comprehensive,
but it is, helps me in that direction.
Just in the last few years, I catch myself when someone's
sharing and they, and I,
and I've had this natural response
to say, I'll be praying for you.
Mm-hmm. If I hear myself say that,
or I'm about to say that, it starts to
Trigger a That that triggers in my mind instead
of saying, I'll be praying for you.
What I'm trying to say now is, can I pray for you right now?
And that's one way to pray without ceasing, is
to pray in those moments and not just say, I'll be praying,
but they're actually do it and then and there together.
And it's, you know, when, when people have done that for me,
it is definitely, uh, been impactful.
Right. Pray together.
Right. That's a good word.
Just you're talking to someone,
they're sharing something right now.
Let's do it right now. Um, obviously situation where that,
that's a really good, and I think we're all talking about
an attitude, a lifestyle of prayer.
Um, So that, that's to me is the idea
of praying without ceasing.
An attitude, a desire to desire to be aware
of the Lord's presence in our lives at all times.
Um, thank you Lord for this day.
Thank you for reviewing the sunshine, this, all those types
of things ever, ever present.
Thank you for the relationship.
Thank you for the day that I've had. Thank you for this.
Thank you for that. Um, element, bit of praise, a lot of
that, but also just to be willing to stop at certain times
and have protect for people, um,
into restaurants.
People come contact in opportunities.
People Often, they, they recognize it about you.
They, they will often ask you to pray for you.
Just to tag on to what, as Jennifer said, one
of the things that sticks out in my mind all years
of point out is
probably when I go out with others to go out
and see homeless and pray for people out the street, is
that spirit of brokenness when I pray for them and they turn
and say, I'm pray for you.
And some most powerful prayers I've ever heard from homeless
people that are really broken
And, uh, They're praying for me.
And that's very powerful.
So can I have one quick testimony? Yeah. Good.
I just got a voice message.
It wasn't voice message on my phone, a text message.
It was a voice one from a gentleman I
met about two weeks ago.
And so he didn't text me.
He sent me the today
and I said, Hey Robert, um,
so if I meet you a few weeks ago,
I just thinking about you today.
I just want to pray for you.
And so he just prayed right then and there
and he sent me the recorded prayer like right now.
Yeah, that was a big surprise. And um, so
That's a good example.
One example. Well, thank you.
I really appreciate the discussion and your thoughts.
Um, we could spend many sessions on prayer.
In fact, uh, seems like I involved in a class nights.
We talk about six weeks on prayer, if I remember right.
Um, let's move on.
But first Hebrews chapter 4, 14 16.
It says, since then, we have a great high priest
who has past through the heavens, Jesus the son of God,
let us fall past our confession.
But we do not have a high priest who is unable
to sympathize with our weaknesses.
For one who in every respect, who has been tempted
as we are yet without sin.
Let us then with confidence drawn near to the throne
of grace that we may receive mercy
and find grace to help die of need.
So Hebrews four, 14th 16.
From the second part of our, uh, time, I is
dealing with angels and satan and demons.
I'll turn it over here to Jacob here in a minute.
But, uh, uh, again, the timing, uh,
especially on the heart regarding the second of demons.
And then we have Halloween in two days
and which is not a favorite day of mine,
but anyway, it's my own personal problem.
Um, angels are defined as angels are created
spiritual beings with moral judgment and high intelligence,
but without physical bodies.
Um, spiritual beings is another name, sons
of God, the holy ones ministering, spirits, watchers,
thrones, dominions, rulers, authorities and power.
There are other kinds of heavenly beings.
Um, what is mentioned is the Cherin, uh, mentioned
as guarding the entrance of the Garden
of Eden in Genesis 3 24.
Also two golden figures of Cherin
with their wing stretched over the Ark of the Covenant.
In Exodus chapter 25, the Lord is instructing Moses,
that the people of Israel were
to make him a sanctuary at tabernacle
and the furniture to be contained therein.
And he gave very specific instructions regarding the arc
of the covenant and for you Raiders of the lost arc fans.
You might remember, I might have seen the movie's idea of
what the arc looks like,
but specifically beginning in verse 17 of chapter 25,
it says, Lord's instructing that says,
you shall make a mercy seat of pure gold.
Two cubits and a half shall be its length and a cubit
and a half its bread.
And you shall make two cher him of gold of hammered work.
So you make them on the two ends of the mercy seat,
you make one cher him, one on the one end
and one cher him on the other end of one piece
for the mercy seat show, you make the chair on its two ends.
The cherin shall spread out their wings, their faces, one
to another toward the mercy seat.
Show the faces of the chair of Ofd
and you shall put the mercy seat on the top of the ark.
And in the ark you shall put the testimony
that I shall give you there.
I'll meet with you. And from above the mercy seat from
between the two Cher of him that are on the ark
of the testimony, I'll speak with you about all
that I will give you and commandment
for the people of Israel.
So surely with that precise description,
we can see the importance of
and the significance of the Chairman, the Lord
at least describe in Exodus chapter 25,
Sarah F mentioned to only in Isaiah six, chapter six,
verse two, seven, Isaiah's vision in the Lord.
He saw the seraphim
and he heard them proclaiming, holy, holy,
holy is the Lord of host.
The whole earth was full of his glory.
And then one of the seraphim flew to Isaiah
and touched a burning cold in his mouth
and said, said, behold, this has touched your lips.
Your guilt is taken away
and your sin is a con for the term.
Living creatures was mentioned in Ezekiel
and Revelation as other kinds of heavenly being.
They worship God continually day and night.
They never cease to say Holy, holy,
holy is the Lord God Almighty, who was and is to come.
Revelation four A.
So I think, uh, Jacob's gonna come
and talk a little bit about, I just wanna mention quickly,
uh, in guardian angels in general, uh,
angels protect us, um, guard us.
But do we have specific individual guardian angels?
Don't think so. Uh, I have a close friend who worked for me
for many years who very much believed in guardian angels.
And every Christmas she would give angels
to my daughters as gifts.
Um, so angels show the greatness
of God's love and for us.
Um, what do angels have to do with us today?
Um, I'll let Jacob share about some
of those things, but, uh, he also should be some caution.
And then Jacob also talk about demons. Jacob over
To be finished.
You got 22 minutes
Set up here. Yeah.
So it's a privilege to get to talk to you all night.
Uh, we'll say it's a little bit too minute though.
When I saw the schedule, I was like, right, there's indeed.
Um, do I need the,
Okay.
Um, so yeah, my name's Jacob Stan.
Um, I said, it's a privilege.
I know some of y'all, some of y'all I don't know.
Um, um, so just one like quick fun fact about
me, love Christmas time.
Um, love everything around it obviously brings our savior.
Um, but I also just love
everything that goes around with it.
I love the lights. Uh, I love the music.
Um, I love the movies
and you know, I have like
traditions, things like to go every year.
One of those is watch certain movies.
And for me, one my favorite movies is it's a wonderful Life.
And so I couldn't help but to think about it
because we talk about angels and demons
and, you know, so much of our, of our, maybe our ideas
of angels and demons can really be influenced by culture,
by movies, TV shows and stuff like that.
So I thought maybe we could do a little better critique
of the movie and see
how accurately it portrays angels for us.
So if you're not familiar with it,
there's a guy's named George Bailey,
and he has a guardian angel named Clarence that comes back
to, to visit him and kind
of helps him see the importance of his life.
So what are some things we learned?
Well, in the movie, they have guardian angels.
They're sent to watch one person
as their, you know, as their guardian.
Angel angels are kind of clumsy, right?
They are guides and they're sent to like,
change their perspective on life.
Uh, it seems like there's kind of a sanctification process
for angels in the movies.
And then of course, the most important fact about angels in
the movie is every time a bell rings
and angel gets your wings.
So I kind of say all that jokingly,
but you know, if we do get our understanding of angel
and demons from movies, uh, we just left
with false theology.
So what do we learn about 'em?
Well, we just look at scripture.
And so as, as Protestants, you know, we affirm so
of fide the scripture is the sole source of, you know,
divine revelation, the only inspired and fallible final
and authoritative norm of faith and practice.
So this includes our view on angels.
So I'm gonna ask a few questions about angels and humans
and we'll see what scripture says about them.
So, and we've gotta start off first. So do angels exist?
Where did they come from? So yes, angels do exist
and God is the one created them.
Uh, and the scripture for this is Nehemiah nine, six.
It says, you are the Lord.
You alone, you have made heaven, the heaven of heavens
with all their hosts, the earth
and all that is on it, the seas and all that is in them.
You preserve all of them, and the host
of heaven worshiped you.
So the host God created them,
and these, the hosts, the angels, they also worship God.
And then there's plenty of
of accounts in the Bible, a few that come to mind.
Two angels come to lie, uh, in Sodom to save his family.
Angel Gabriel announces the birth of Jesus
to Mary, uh, and Luke.
And then, uh, an angel helps Peter escaped from
prison in Acts 12.
And then the guardian angel question from the movie, right?
So we can look at the Bible
and see that God does send angels for our protection.
So Psalm 9, 1 11 says that he will command his angels
concerning you to guard you in all your ways.
So God does enable us to guard us in our ways.
Um, so one question that I have for y'all, thinking
through the Bible, what are some examples in the Bible
of stories where an angel is sentenced to protect someone
Lot in his family?
14, he would accept, protect that
the plane too, you
Talk, talking about when it Detective Moses' body
No, no. She's
talking about Daniel. Yeah.
Was, uh, came to explain history. That's it. Yeah.
Thank you. And
Angel, Joe, like an entire harmony series for Israel.
Okay, what else? Daniel? The lives
Been Delivered
News about John Baptist. Jesus
Anymore?
No. Okay.
He's hungry.
Sue's sued. Mary's scared. Goodbye.
So, and,
and you know, made it that this was, this was something
that God home was divine AEs.
She would be mother inside.
So I guess sharing that intelligence, that information
of god's and confirming and also comfort
When came to the tomb and Jesus' body wasn't there
And the angel said,
Is that what you're asking?
Sure.
That's,
So one more here that I wrote down was,
uh, Elisha's eyes are open.
He sees the mountains filled with horses
and Sherry's a fire all around him.
Does someone else have one over here?
I was gonna say lums don't Yeah,
but that, that was helpful for
Yeah. I'm not sure if that's what you
Mean. Sure.
Yeah.
There's certainly a lot more examples just of angels just,
just kind of beyond, um, you know,
like protecting people in the Bible.
Um, so in, in the book, so just thinking about the idea
of do we have individual guardian angels?
So Gruden uses a sports analogy.
So he says, we should think that angels play zone defense
and not man to man defense.
Um, and so, you know, he says
that there's no convincing scriptural support, um,
for individual guardian angels,
but rather angels in general are protecting God's people.
And then maybe just the last question to ask about angels.
What, what is the purpose of angels?
And so what we see is that humans
and angels are the only moral,
highly intelligent creatures God has made.
And one, one purpose, there was many
of the group listed out, but one person, uh, purpose,
the one that that um, I find a lot of comfort in is
the angels show the greatness
of God's love and planning for us.
So in two Peter two, four,
he's talking about angels, angels sin.
It says, for God did not spare angels.
When they sinned, we cast them into hell
and committed them to change of gloomy darkness
to be kept until judgment.
So the sin, the God did not save them.
He decided to save none of them.
And that was perfectly just for God to do.
As humans, we have sin and we, we have turned from God,
but God gives us grace.
He does decide to save some of us.
And he says in Revelation five, nine, not only some of us,
but a great multitude whom no man can number from every
tribe and language and people and nation.
So as you think about the contrast between angels, sinning
and God, choosing not to save them and us sin
and God choosing to save us.
So just a question that I pose to y'all is what does
that teach you about God's grace
And why?
Sure.
I think it would be important to point out that yeah,
you made two spirit highly intelligent spiritual beings,
but only one of those to be creating his image.
And that's why he can redeem this.
That was what I was gonna say.
It reminds me of the juxtaposition inal made.
What is man that you're mindful of him,
the son of man, that you care for him.
Yeah, you've made them a little lower than the heavenly
beings, but you crown him with glory and honor.
So the angels, when they interact with humans, humans,
humans are usually terrified,
but yet God extended his grace toward, toward us.
It's, it's incredible.
What verse was there I thought was Psalm eight,
Psalm eight, five
in Hebrews two.
What else? Anybody else add anything on that?
Well, to tie into what he's saying, that that that idea
that angles are wonderful, ambassador of God,
That resident yet we're created in his image,
whereas angles are not directly created in.
Okay, so let's move on to talking about demons.
Um, see this list, he has a very quote on this.
He says there's two equal opposite hes into
which our race can fall about.
The devils one is the disbelief in their existence.
The other is to believe and to feel an excessive
and unhealthy interest in them.
You know, our culture is very, um,
it's very naturalistic worldview.
So it's really, Hey, what can you see touch here?
So even just talking about angels
and humans, um, you know, it's not something
that people want to admit or believe in, right?
What a scripture say. Do demons exist?
Yes, God created the world.
He looked at it and said everything was good.
Then we fast forward to Genesis three
and has to have been something that has happened, some sort
of rebelled angelic world
because now we're introduced to this new person, Satan,
um, is not good.
And then Ephesians six 12 tells us we do not wrestle against
flesh and blood, but against the
rulers, against the authorities.
The cosmic powers over this present darkness against the
spiritual forces of evil in the heaven many places.
And then another question to ask,
can a believer be possessed by a demon?
We talk about, do we have guardian angels?
What about who be possessed by demon?
So, uh, ome, he distinguishes
between possession and influence.
So demon possession is often understood, um, to mean
that a person is unable to resist the influence of a demon.
And so this idea of possession is not a biblical one.
So scripture guarantees that
that sin shall dominion over us since
we've been raised with Christ.
But we do look at scripture.
We can say that demons do have influence
over people even and over believers.
Um, and it's found in scripture, uh,
varying degrees of influence.
So for example, Luke 13, um, a woman has said
to have a disabling spirit and she was bound
by Satan for 18 years.
And then last, what, what is our authority
as believers over demons?
So Jesus gives us disciples power
and authority over all demons.
In Luke nine, one and his authority,
it continues to all believers.
It's evidenced by Paul using his
spiritual authority over demons and acts.
And then James and Peter tell other readers
that they have authority and power to resist the devil
and he will free from you.
This goes back to can we be possessed or,
or can we be influenced by demons?
Well, it tells us we resist the devil.
He will free from you. So why do we
have authority over demons?
The finish work of Jesus on the cross is our authority
as believers over demons at the cross.
God dis on the rulers and authorities
and put them to open chain by trumping over them in here.
And this is my favorite one.
From there it says lastly, our confidence
and our authority comes through our
status as God's children.
When demons, when they attempt to influence us, they must go
through our Heavenly Father.
It's that, oh, you know, my dad can be up, your dad pain.
It's like, well, if you wanna come at me,
you gotta go through my father first.
So that can give us a lot of confidence over the meetings.
So my last question just for y'all is kind of goes back to
that CS Lewis quote, how do we maintain a healthy,
balanced view of angels and demons without falling into
either fear or like fascination with her?
Stay focused on Scriptures?
I think we need to recognize constant s
What else?
Power, evil, But limited.
So that's the balance. Recognizing that there is power,
but that is limited by God.
Yes, The word victory comes to my mind.
So we don't wrestle against flesh
and blood against the spiritual forces.
So the more engaging
and maybe challenging situations to acknowledge that
and then to go to God in prayer
and asking for him to step in
and remove, to resist divine, to review
to, to deal with that.
And so that's an opportunity for us to exercise prayer
'cause he's the one who grants us the victory.
When I was reading that chapter and thinking about it
and making my notes on it, I, what came to my mind was, uh,
a phrase, it shows my age.
The devil made me do it.
And I think it was a comedian that came up with that phrase
and studied, uh, I guess, um,
the idea that the devil makes us do things
as an excuse for our behavior.
Mm-hmm. Um, if I thought more about it, it was, uh,
really an absurd thought process is that, um, again,
the influence as opposed to possession
and what we choose to be around and have.
But I often remember we were in Nicaragua one time
and we were near a village
and someone was talking to us
and said, well, this, this particular village was a really
dark history, uh, um,
and the spirit of, of, of,
of demon influence in this village.
And so, um, that was a, that was an opportunity for prayer,
an opportunity for to be be in that division, but
but also be aware of that.
It's, it's there Definitely we
Have to recognize.
I sort of want to add to Lewis's quote, what did he say?
Fear and fascination.
Uh, it says there's two op equal opposite errors.
One is the disbelief.
There's sense the others to believe and feel
An excessive healthy interest.
Okay? Yeah. And then there's sort of fear and fascination.
I think there's also confusion, like we strive more power to
evils than it actually has.
Like it's evil, it's powerful,
but it wants to magnify that in our minds.
Like the rivalry is actually kind of
superpower and lose it about,
but it's just not name y it's not a, it's not dualistic.
It's uh, it's a temporary
and limited force that wants you
to think it's more powerful than actually
Were playing from the w playing from the w picture.
I just have a mental picture.
Is it in pilgrim's progress where he has to go to the house
and he's got these big lions, he has the walkthrough?
No, Those lions are on a chain
and if calls the light
and on the path, they're, they're constrained
so they can gore and they can intimidate and generate fear.
But the victory is by following that light.
And that's a mental picture of the reality of
those dark spirits,
but the victory that we did in Jesus, who they on,
You know, uh, excuse me while I connect this,
I'm gonna have to shorter than all you guys.
Um, one thing I like to ask
whenever thinking about angels is, um,
what kind are we talking about?
Right? You know, how many their angelic beings, you know,
seraphim share them.
If I can get this, uh,
lemme know when you get it out not working.
I upgrade my technology.
Did you guys all get, did you guys all get your memory
reverse card here in a minute.
If you don't have one, then grab, look at your neighbors.
Grab it here a minute. Um,
what we'll do is take a minute and pray that to together.
I love this. I dunno if you've ever seen this me.
You got, it's like one of the living creatures for Ezekiel.
And it says, be not afraid.
And this guy says, sir,
this is the scariest moment of my life.
You know, uh, I think it was Al Moler, you know,
the president of Southern Seminary.
He said, uh, biblically typically what happens when somebody
actually encounters an angel in the Bible
is they pee their pants.
And, um, because they always say don't be afraid, right?
So there's something awesome about them, you know,
and it reflects the glory of God.
And, uh, just a good reminder.
They're always saying, Hey, don't worship me. Right?
There's something awesome about them,
but there's also, uh, well,
just a reflection of the glory of God.
I think, uh, the other thing I was thinking about about
with prayer, I just wanted to add is that I think, you know,
whenever, like we've justing about all the things we've
talked about just now, when we think about the nature
of God, uh, one of them is that, that, that the idea
of prayer, the topic of prayer reminds us that
it's something about God.
It reminds us specifically about God
himself, his very nature.
And, uh, it reminds us that God, uh, that God speaks
and that God hears, like these are things
that are true about him.
He, he is a communicating God and he wants us, he
and Vigi commands us to relate to him.
And uh, and I think sometimes we confuse prayer,
but I'm just asking for things.
Uh, I'm just telling God my complaints
and all those things are relevant.
We do ask for things. We do express our, our desires,
even our, our struggles to God.
But, but fundamentally, I think the more we know who he is
and what he's like, the more easily we pray.
Because it's just like learning to communicate
with any other person.
Like he's a real person.
And, uh, and we communicate about things.
You, we think about if you're married
or a friendship that you have,
or what we express things we need and want.
But that is like not the only thing
that we talk about, right?
So we relate to each other.
We express love and affection for each other.
We communicate about all kinds of things.
So we recognize God speaks to us primarily in His Word,
and then we respond to his word by thinking about it.
Uh, reading, in listening, listening to God in His Word.
And then we respond in prayer. In, in how many ways?
In like every way that God's word addresses.
We, we talked to God about that, interact with, uh,
we've already talked about this, mentioned that a couple
of books I wanted to wave around one.
This is Steve. This the book you taught, I think it was, uh,
one of the first classes I took here was Steve's class on
prayer, praying, the Praying with Paul by DA Carson.
David, I know your favorite author. Yeah, sure.
Uh, as a staff.
We read this recently, earlier this year,
A Praying Life by Paul Miller.
Just real practical, I'd recommend that praying the Bible
by Donald Whitney is really practical way of just walking
through thinking about you.
I don't know what to pray. Well, God said a lot.
So like, read God's word and pray God's word.
And, um, anyway, good.
Another book by Don Whitney's,
spiritual Disciplines for the Christian Life.
His chapter on, on prayer is great.
I would recommend all those.
Um, but
before we wrap up here, I just wanted to take a minute,
James four, seven to eight, if you guys have that.
Let's just take a moment.
Sorry, I turned off my, I'll come back to that.
Um, James 4, 7, 8.
It says, submit yourselves
therefore to God, resist the devil
and he will flee from you, draw near to God
and he will draw near to you though one
of the reasons I love this verse
for this topic is it talks about
everything that we talked about tonight.
It talks about prayer, it talks about resisting the devil,
it talks about the spiritual realities that are around us.
And so I'd like to just take a moment and, um,
and let's just pray through this.
Let's take 60 seconds and, and any
and any of you want to just sort of jump in in response to
what God has said in his word.
And let's pray. I'll start
and then we'll take a few minutes.
Please join in and then I'll close us.
Father, we thank you for the light of this specific word
that we read in James four, seven to eight.
There's a lot more that it says,
but first off, it says, we should submit to you.
And so, Lord, we do, we've said a lot of words tonight.
We've thought a lot of thoughts about you.
We've talked about you and about the spiritual realm
and the world you have made.
But what we do right now is we just
surrender ourselves to you.
Thank you for the invitation.
We thank you, Lord, for the opportunity to relate to you,
to communicate with you, to come near to you.
And so we begin there
I, whether you are God and
those two, be that people
that just honors you with our lips, but our hearts apart
From,
And the next part of this, we see the reality
of a malevolent spiritual force, the devil.
And, uh, we are told to resist him.
He does want
to make us do things like Steve was talking about there.
There are times that even feels like that, that,
that some other, that an enemy force made me
do the things I do.
And we do know that we wrestle against
indwelling sin in our lives.
We also wrestle against the personal reality
of evil in the devil and his angels, the demonic forces.
And so, Lord, we, we, we need your grace
and strength to resist him.
But I, I hear in this verse the reality that, that we can
actually resist him in Christ.
That there are things we can do to, to resist.
And there's a promise that when we do that,
he will flee from us.
Indeed, this last verse as we close, draw near to God
and he will draw near to you again.
Lord, we thank you for the invitation that you are there,
that you are real, that you are with us, that you speak,
that you hear, that you listen.
That you want to be known by us.
Indeed, you've made us in your image, you made us
with the ability to communicate one with another.
And it reflects the reality of our ability
to communicate also with you.
And that your, and your willingness and desire
and ability to communicate with us the Lord, we love you.
We thank you for your grace in our lives
as this verse goes on.
And there's confession of sin to which Lord, we claim
and admit our great need of your forgiveness
and mercy for all of our sin
and rebellion against you, not only in our past,
but even perhaps even today.
The struggles we'll face tomorrow, Lord,
that's it's not right.
And yet we're weak and we struggle and we draw near to you.
And we pray for grace and mercy in
helping in our time with need.
In Jesus name. Amen. Amen.
Um, we've got, I, I'm here long.
If you need to go, uh, please feel free.
What I'd like sign your roster first, what I'd like
to do is just take a minute and sing a song together.
Um, so if you guys need to go, uh, it's time's up.
So feel free to take off.
But I'd like to sing A Mighty Fortress is Our God.
And, uh, if you're willing to stay, um, stand up, join us,
and, uh, you gotta go sing it on your way.
You pick that song out. I picked it.
I was thinking about that. Oh really?
I,
Good job.